Everybody in the street knows the
political center has failed. Everybody
knows. So something has to change.
There's a quote from Milton Friedman,
American economist. At times of crisis,
the new idea will be chosen from the
ideas lying around at the time.
Everybody knows that we will get
something new in politics. And it is
really obvious what the loudest idea
lying around now is, which is the far
right. And the second loudest idea is
us, tax the rich. So if you are a
billionaire and you know that politics
is going to move either towards the far
right or tax the rich, what are you
going to do? You are going to fund the
far right and they are doing it
aggressively. Look at what Elon Musk is
doing. These guys know that they don't
want to pay high taxes and they are
correct that the way to prevent yourself
from having to pay high taxes is to
aggressively fund the far